[Music]
this episode is brought to you by kettle
and fire which makes some of the best
bone broth and certainly the most
convenient that I've ever found and I
have a big stack of them on my kitchen
counter right now I have one container
every morning and this first came highly
recommended to me by past podcast guests
such as Amelia Boone who's a four-time
world champion in world stops mutter
Spartan Race etc and dr. Dominic
D'Agostino The Incredible Hulk of
scientific research you should check him
out too but there are a few things that
make kettle and fire special number one
they are the first shelf stable in other
words never frozen bone broth that uses
bones from 100% grass-fed organically
raised animals so you are what you eat
eight if that makes sense so it's very
important that you understand if you're
consuming animal protein what they
consumed they also use longer cook times
20 plus hours which means more collagen
and other nutrients for instance they
contain 19 times more collagen than one
of their close competitors and an
independent lab confirm this I'll leave
the competitor's name out of it because
I don't want to get sued but that's the
case and it is not frozen so thanks to
many millions of dollars of packaging
equipment their bone broth doesn't
require freezing or shipping with dry
ice so like I said it's just sitting on
my kitchen counter in these boxes and
then I can heat them up they're
basically ready to drink heat them up on
stove top or in a microwave and you are
ready to rock and roll you also get a
nice payload of glucosamine glycine
along with the gelatin and everything
else that I mentioned so check it out I
have been hugely pleased with this and
like I said I've been consuming it every
morning it gives you about let's say 20
grams of protein which is a nice little
slow carb diet' boost if that's what
you're looking for then I'll tip
this out of a very large camping coffee
mug as I do some writing or journaling
so there you have it check it out it's
delicious I favor the chicken but each
to his own or her own so check it out
kettle and feiyr.com forward slash to
him and you can receive 20% off of your
entire order take a look
kettle and feiyr.com forward slash Tim
this episode is brought to you by ascent
protein the cleanest least processed
protein I've ever consumed and I have
tried just about everything since well
before the 4-hour body I've started my
day with 20 to 30 grams of protein first
thing that has been part of my routine
but I don't always have the time or
necessarily the desire to cook an entire
meal so what to do protein powders can
be a fast way to get this protein need
met but most products are full of crap
they're bleached they have excess sugar
terrible artificial sweeteners or just
straightforward low-grade low quality
protein a scent contains zero artificial
ingredients and the parent company is
actually cheese manufacturers so that
they produce their own native proteins
it's it's really fascinating and I've
looked at their processing it takes or
it took them about five years to develop
you can mix the protein in as little as
four ounces without any clumps or issues
of mix ability whatsoever and they
nailed the taste they tested it for
instance there's the chocolate version
two hundred and eighty two different
versions they put a lot of money and a
lot of time into R&D for this particular
product and they have both way and my
seller casings so if you want to say
improve body composition and recovery
overnight slow release you can take the
micellar casein or in my case whey
protein I would take post-workout for
instance or in the morning so check it
out these guys are really fascinating
visit a scent protein dot-com forward
slash Tim that's ASC ENT PR OT ein
dot-com a scent like first descent going
up ascent protein comm forward slash Tim
you will receive 20% off your entire
purchase if you want a very quick 20 or
30 gram dose to start your day or after
workout this is a fantastic option it is
arguably the best that I've found so
again check it out a scent protein com
forward slash Tim hello my lady Mogwai
this is Tim Ferriss and welcome to
another episode of the Tim Ferriss show
where it is my job to distill extract
deconstruct the habits routines and
tactics of world-class performers of all
different types whether they are
billionaires chess prodigies elite
athletes or otherwise and in this case
we have elite athlete Maria Sharapova
and man oh man that I have a lot of fun
with this conversation we got deep into
the tactics of training and mental
performance mental toughness and much
much more you can find her on Facebook
Sharapova you can find her on Twitter
and Instagram at Maria Sharapova who is
Maria Sharapova she is the winner of
five Grand Slam titles and is an Olympic
silver medalist she is only one of a
handful of players to hold all four
Grand Slam titles including Wimbledon US
Open Australian Open and Roland Garros
she has held the world number one
ranking for 21 weeks and has won 35
singles titles in her career Forbes also
named her the highest paid female
athlete of all time in 2005 she's now
held that title for a record 11 years
for 12 years that is a long time Maria
Garner's worldwide press coverage on and
off the court with a social media
presence that includes 15.5 probably a
lot more at this point Facebook fans
more than 6.5 million Twitter followers
2.7 million followers on Instagram she
serves as an ambassador to many of the
world's top luxury brands and a number
of Fortune 500 companies including
Porsche Nike Avion and head in 2007 she
became a goodwill ambassador for the
United Nations Development Programme
UNDP and has made significant
contributions to Chernobyl related
projects in her name
country 2012 Sharapova flexed her
entrepreneurial muscles and debuted her
eponymous Couture candy collection sugar
Hova most recently she is the author of
a book titled unstoppable my life so far
it describes her story in detail and was
done in collaboration with an incredible
writer named rich Cohen which we'll get
into but a few things that we don't get
into we don't talk about meldonium we
don't talk about the sponsors we don't
talk about handful things that have been
talked to death in the media we dig into
more of the specifics that you can use
the specifics that will inspire you and
also instruct you that you can apply so
that was the focus and I really hope you
enjoy this as much as I did it was a
blast and it inspired me in fact among
other things to who come to Florida
where I am right now I have compression
sleeve on my right arm
why because I'm doing tennis camp I'm
doing an intense immersive tennis
program at the Human Performance
Institute with Jim Lehrer
that's LOH are and you should definitely
check out the Human Performance
Institute with Jim Lehrer it's
phenomenal and I've been playing my
little heart out in tennis which I've
always wanted to do my entire life for
the last two days and have a few more
days to go but Maria really piqued my
interest in this sport which I'd wanted
to do for so so long and put off and I
realized you know rather than doing
jiu-jitsu and all these things that
break my body the gentle art maybe I
should try something like tennis golf
not my speed I'd rather just go for a
hike but tennis yeah I like the sound of
that
and I like watching it so even if just
to get a better appreciation of the
sport so that I can see the nuances and
details when watching tennis on TV
tennis said Sean Connery all right I
need to go have a drink and dinner in
any case without further ado please
enjoy this wide-ranging conversation
with Maria Sharapova
Maria welcome to the show thank you I am
so thrilled that we were able to carve
out time and I have so many questions I
will start with a rather simple one I'm
sitting here drinking tea I'm having a
Charleston breakfast tea and I have
heard that you also enjoy tea is that
true and if so what type of tea do you
prefer what are your go-to teas so I
grew up in Russia where tea it's a big
part of our culture's drinking tea and
the afternoons with your grandparents so
I drink black tea a darjeeling type of
tea that was made in the mountains
in Siberia and I would have it with with
raspberry jam that my grandmother would
make that sounds amazing so would you
put the jam on a piece of toast and have
it or no I actually I put it in my tea
and I still do that and just so many
memories of my childhood and yeah I do
that instead of sugar which is pretty
much the same thing but it gives you
permission and yeah you mentioned
Siberia which is where I want to go next
you were born in Siberia as I understand
it but your mother was pregnant with you
while in Chernobyl so can you explain
what happened exactly my parents were
from go Mel it was a very small town
very close to where the Chernobyl
reactor blew up and during that time
just before my mother was pregnant with
me in 1986 and they fled there was not a
lot of information about what happened
during Chernobyl my grandparents were
living in Siberia at the time from from
my mom's side and they said you need to
get out of there they were able to get
more information about the disaster
itself than my parents were able to get
to being so close to to the area and and
they left and that's why I was born in
Siberia your family fled to
I guess Russia right after the explosion
but you ended up in I guess a warmer
place or at least depending on the
season this is not going to work out
over here and they moved to a resort
town Sochi where it just had the Winter
Olympics and one of the I mean I still
consider it one of the most beautiful
places to visit because you have the
Black Sea and you have the palm trees in
the summer and just an hour away you
have these mountains where the Olympics
were held and some of the best skiing in
the world my dad still skis there all
the time so yeah I definitely it's one
of the most peaceful places as well if I
go to Russia I've never visited Russia
I've always wanted to are there one or
two places that I absolutely must visit
in your mind there any particular things
that I cannot miss I know it's a
gigantic place all right I would say
skip Siberia definitely not much to see
or do over there but I think from from a
cultural standpoint I would definitely
visit st. Petersburg and it is still a
place that I've never been to you can
believe it or not as much as I've
traveled around the world but my mom
goes almost every year a lot of my
relatives are there and I just I have
this enormous you know respect for the
culture and just the city and the people
and the way they live it's very
different and you know people always ask
me as I was born in Russia and I spent
the first seven years of my life there
and I've lived a night in the United
States ever since and you know I've
never really looked back onto living in
Russia but so much of my heart still
remains there and obviously my all of my
grandparents and my cousins all still
live there and so it's a very big part
of my life and when people ask me what I
think about the country as much as I
want to have an opinion it is so large
and it is so vast and there's so many
opinions you can have about it and I
really just want to let people
experience it on their own and come to
their own conclusions
I think that's one of the greatest
things of travel is to not have
expectations and to get there and to
experience a new place but st.
Petersburg is on my list and that's
definitely a city that comes highly
recommended why have you not been there
and I mean maybe it's something like the
me growing up in New York I'd never ever
visited the Empire State Building or the
Statue of Liberty until a friend from
Germany visited another reason it's
because of my schedule it's so I mean I
compete ten months out of the year and
it is pretty much go to the same cities
of every year because the tournaments
are all situated in those same cities
when I have a holiday break which
usually consists of a couple of weeks
only in November I go somewhere warm I
just escape you know I put my phone away
put just everything on hold a little bit
and just let my body and my mind recover
and it just never has been never has
come into yeah into my schedule
warmer places we talked about phew and
of course there's California there's
Florida then there's Sochi so going back
to Sochi is that where you were first
noticed yes you tell the story of how
you were first found as it were as it
relates to tennis yes so Sochi in the
summer it was very much a happening
place there was a scene and it was a lot
of a lot of people were coming there on
vacations we had a lot of little parks
and outdoor tennis courts and Ferris
wheels and all these types of
attractions and my father who was not a
great athlete but he played hockey and
in school he enjoyed playing tennis he
was not very good at all
did it for fun and when I was old enough
to go with him and my mother had me when
she was very young she was only 20 years
old so she was still studying at the
time so on weekdays when my father
didn't have to work he would take me
with him to the local park and I would
just follow along and then we take the
public bus to the courts and and I just
sit there and I'd watch him you know
grind it out with with
competitor of his and and then I'd see
all these little kids playing on on the
side and they were just hitting balls
against the wall and I didn't have you
know I didn't have a racket of my own
and and the one that I was able to get
was so much bigger than myself
so that didn't really work out but I
immediately something like something
drew me to it something drew me to this
like repetitiveness of seeing these kids
try to hit the ball against the strings
of the racket and see it come back from
the wall and who's very fascinating it
was like I had this immediate feeling of
I want to be in front of those kids and
I want to show them how it's done
yeah it was a very even though I had no
idea what I was doing so I think that
competitiveness kind of developed then
where I was just sitting and bored and
watching my father play I just wanted to
be out there it was it a feeling that
you could do it more correctly and just
something that you intuited that you
felt intuitively or was it because you
noticed flaws in their technique or
things that they were missing I'm always
curious about this because one of my
closest friends his name is Josh
Waitzkin and the book and the movie
searching for bobby fisher' were based
on him he's thought of as a chess
prodigy and he had this experience very
very early on with chess what did it
mean of course might be difficult to
recall what was going through your head
at the time but can you elaborate at all
I think from my perspective when you're
that young and when you don't know
anything about that particular activity
or that's sport and it was tennis in
that moment it was really this a
question of can I do that I see all
these kids doing it do I have the
ability to be better than them and after
observing for of so much of what my
father was doing just not on any
professional level at all it just came
to my mind that I wanted to do it and I
wanted to do it better I think there is
a times in life where things come
instinctually and and you just grasp it
and you notice it and I think my father
definitely noticed I could have kept
sitting on that bench and I just could
have kept watching my father but there's
something in me that was that said no I
want to be out there I want to be
playing and I'm
to be competing and I want to be
learning and when I got myself out to
that the wall were all the kids were
hitting the ball against I remember a
coach there's one coach there and he all
the locals were all the children were
going to see him all the parents wanted
him to tell him that that they're gonna
be future stars they're gonna be the
next Pete Sampras to the next Andre
Agassi and he noticed me and only after
a couple of weeks and when I was playing
and he pulled my father aside and said
that this girl can play tennis and after
that I started taking lessons with him
and a couple of years after that there
was a an exhibition that Martina
Navratilova was a part of and I was
about five and a half years old at that
time an exhibition was being held in
Moscow so my father and I went to Moscow
and I was probably one out of 200 kids
in that clinic that she was holding for
these kids and after hitting a few balls
I I noticed that she had come up to my
father and I don't quite know in what
language they spoke because my father
didn't speak any English and I'm pretty
sure she didn't have much Russian but
between the two and and after she left I
spoke to my father and he said well this
legend Martina Navratilova just came up
to me and said that you're talented and
this was only after her watching me just
hit a couple of balls in the midst of so
many other kids and and that's you know
I look back at that and I because I see
so many kids now I practiced at a
country club and you know there's all
these just today I was practicing next
to two little girls are probably seven
or eight years old just enjoying the
game on by themselves and kind of trying
to hit the ball over the net and it's
hard to to envision that talent it's
hard to see it so for her to be able to
see that when I was only five and a half
years old was pretty incredible
do you have any idea have either of
these the either the first coach or
Martina
later told you what they saw
have you any idea what it was that they
picked up on I haven't spoken to Martina
about it too much but the first coach
that I had in Sochi and I just started
playing he unfortunately passed away a
few years ago but I definitely had this
tenacity and I had this will of a focus
at a young age and and tennis is a very
repetitive sport so you it's grinding
it's just hitting the ball and when
you're that young your concentration and
focus is just all over the place you
play with with the ball for a few
minutes and then you want to play with
your truck or you want to play with a
doll and you the consistency and in your
mind is very limited at least that's
what when I observe kids which is
completely normal but I had this I had
this fascination with being able to hit
the ball and and seeing somebody else
hit it back at me and trying to find a
way and the racket that I first had was
actually we had to cut the grip by like
four or five inches because it was it
was so much bigger than I was and I
could barely hold it and it was so heavy
and so it's just this really funny scene
of me trying to figure out how to cuz
when you're just given a ball in a
racket and like well what do I do with
this now so I just picture myself there
just trying to find a way to get the
ball over the net and I had this
determination of of doing it better and
better every day and I and I stuck to it
it was never I don't remember one day
where I didn't want to go down the steps
of our apartment and walk the 20 minutes
uphill to get to the bus station and
then have to change buses to the next
station
there's never a day where I said you
know what I don't I don't want to do it
and I think there's you know that's not
something that just that you had that
you can really teach or that you know
you could develop it but I think I just
I really loved it and and I carry that
passion this idea that you were able to
hold constant in your mind this
fascination of tennis and practice
consistently what did your as context
for myself what did your dad do for
and you mentioned your mother was
studying what was she studying if you
could tell us a little bit about them
she was studying communications and
business and I had a very interesting
childhood because my parents were both
they're very young and they had no
knowledge you know what to do I was the
first child I'm still the only child but
they were very careful of what the
decisions that they made and where I was
going to go and if I was going to go to
kindergarten or how long me wanted me to
be there and I spent so many hours in
the library with my mother while she was
doing her homework or she was studying
for an exam and then I'd go with my
father when he leisurely play tennis my
father worked in construction mm-hmm had
a fairly normal job I would say we ruin
average family getting support from from
both of our grandparents for my moms and
my dad side and you know we lived a very
basic and you know at that time a very
normal life did they expose you to a lot
of other things besides tennis and some
things you had zero interest in and you
had that kid like distraction or ADH do
you like the inability to focus or jumpy
focus and then tennis was the one thing
that you gravitated towards and really
locked on to or were you like that with
everything it happened so fast and
because I had only started picking up
the tennis track when I was four years
old at the age of six and a half I was
already on an iron flock flight to
America a lot of time to test things I
love doctor I love to read my mother was
very much into education and she's um
she didn't want anything to do with
tennis she didn't want anything to do
with sport she danced ballet a little
bit and she was she brought a lot of the
cultural educational the learning and
the growing in your mind experiences to
me I mean she would read passages and
and novels that I was way too young to
understand but she made me memorize a
lot of those passages and something
about that that repetitiveness I never I
never liked to do it but it was a sense
of discipline that that she taught me in
a way that had nothing to do with sport
and I think that really I mean I would
spend an hour in the evening just
memorizing these poems by Pushkin
and thinking to myself when am I ever
going to use this and little do you know
with years and especially now that I'm
older
you know discipline doesn't always come
so easy in it you have to build its
foundations and you have to build the
trust with the people that help you with
it and I think her influence and her
ability to to acknowledge that as a
young mom was so inspirational and that
that discipline really comes into play
as a tennis player because you have to
have so much of it I mean their
sacrifice and theirs their the long days
but the discipline that you have to
carry on with whether it's a good day or
a bad day just beats everything else so
I got chills about 47 seconds ago
because I looking at the time because I
found out I was digging for in it I
wasn't looking for any particular answer
but I want to just underscore a few
things you said for people who might be
parents because of the 250 plus
interviews that I've done for this
podcast there are a couple of patterns
that have emerged in people who've
become really really really good at
something really early and ultimately
really mastered anything even if at that
age 10 15 20 so the first is that I've
noticed and it's not for everyone but
their parents talked to them at least
part of the time about subject matter
above their heads so to speak or as
adults and number two is a lot of
exposure to books number three was what
you brought up and this is what I got
excited about which is developing a
tolerance for repetition
and in some cases for that type of not
going to say boredom but lack of a
variety in some capacity because I think
that that like you said your your
training that so that it can then be
applied to other things so you might say
why am i memorizing these poems is I'm
never going to use these poems but at
the same time you're developing the
ability to tolerate the thousands of
hours that you're going to put into
hitting a ball against a wall yes and
it's the it's the persistence that
you're building it's the will that when
you know I believe in any job that we do
any work that we have in front of us
there's a lot of moments that are that
we look forward to there are projects
that we love and that we want to be a
part of but then there's the the tedious
work there's the things that the the
repetition as a tennis player where you
have to just where it's all numbers and
where it's just a feeling that you get
to a certain number and you just feel it
and you let go and you don't think and
that's time you know and that it's you
could say I don't want to do it I die I
want to stop I don't want you feeding me
any more balls but that that mental
persistence
I do think you could you can develop
earlier I certainly was able to with the
help of my mother and and also I mean I
when you're young do you and she was a
very young parent and you know with the
help of her mother and also culturally I
would say 30 years ago 25 years ago it
was very different and I felt like I was
in her cocoon and I was I was grown up
in her hands which also I think explains
the bond that we have today and like the
friendship that we were able to have
from that and I think that's one of the
most important things in my life as I as
I travel around the world today and I I
meet a lot of young girls and boys
whether they play tennis or not and I
hear their stories and so much of their
experiences is a very tough and rough
childhood where they want to they almost
want to escape from
from what what they knew as their family
and so sad personally because the
experience that I had in my childhood
and it was not I'm not saying it was all
butterflies and rainbows but as I look
back at that experience and how they
were handling that situation how they
were sacrificing so much for myself
created this bond within my family that
was very important and it's it's
priceless and I know that those are not
the people that we thought we were able
to choose in our life but they are the
people that know is the best and that
relationship can do so many wonders in
your life because I feel like your mom
is such an important figure in
relationship I noticed that you've been
reading memoirs written by women and
feel free to correct anything I get
wrong but most notably love warrior by
Glenn and Bill Melton and Jeannette
Walls the glass castle and you called
them quote very strong tough emotional
books and quote what did what did those
two books mean to you why were they
tough and emotional like what did you
take away from that
I'm the variance I get very inspired by
women
I get very inspired by their their brain
by their actions by their toughness I
think in today's world and in today's
working environment and I face this a
lot in my sport where you know I could
be going into a press conference six
times in a week and I'm faced with
equality questions and I'm you almost
have your back against the wall so many
times and you have to explain yourself
and and you feel that you've done it so
many times and can you explain that just
for a second in terms of explaining
yourself for quality questions would you
tell us a little bit more about that you
know we I mean equality has been a big
big subject in women's tennis for many
many years and Venus Williams and Serena
herself
have done an incredible job of getting
to where we are today with the helps of
the pioneer Billie Jean King was the
reason why we we make such an incredible
living from what we do and the one thing
that we as
as professional athletes have to realize
is we're not just we're not only
fighting to win a tennis match we're
also fighting to be an example we're
fighting for our voice we're fighting to
have a pedestal to create that pedestal
and to raise awareness of how incredible
and how difficult and how each path is
so unique and personal and how we're all
able to come through it how we are able
to share our stories who are able to
inspire other people and not just women
it's it's women and and men as well do
we get enough credit for it I don't
believe so
and when I say that that's what we have
to explain I believe that that's that
that's the feeling that I have at least
and I don't feel that we have the amount
of support that that we should be having
I was having a conversation with a very
learned man I guess would be the easiest
way to put it today and asking him for
advice or done a few things and he said
that help the greatest number of people
become an example so in other words you
don't have to work and in hand with each
individual person but
if you have the visibility and exposure
as you do to become an example of
potential I think that's extremely
important but I had very unusual
beginnings all of this in many respects
right and you ended up at a very young
age at the Nick Bollettieri tennis
academy in the US which is produced you
mentioned the Williams sisters Andre
Agassi Boris Becker how did you end up
there and could you tell us a bit about
the coaching methodology because that's
always what I'm just so endlessly
fascinated by so I think my father's
point of view after that children's
clinic that Martina Navratilova held was
tennis is not it was not a big sport at
that time in Russia we didn't have many
champions coming out of the country I
believe at the time it was your Kenny
Kafelnikov and Anna Kournikova but other
than that it was hockey it was figure
skating it was all the Winter Olympic
sports and I mean one it was very
expensive to to find the right coaches
to find the right facilities especially
in the winter time so the only real
option was America and my father started
reading books and studying the game and
he knew that he wasn't a tennis coach
and he knew that he wasn't a great
tennis player and the smart I would say
one of the the biggest gifts that my
father gave me and started from a very
young age was that he realized that he
he wasn't the one that was going to be
my main coach he wasn't the one that
knew everything or believed to know
everything he wanted to get the help
from others and so he started doing
research and next thing I knew just
before my seventh birthday I was on a
flight to to Miami Florida and from
there we made this crazy bus journey
four hours north to the voluntary
Academy and Bradenton Florida which says
as you just mentioned so many of the the
stars past and present and future at the
moment it's really a factory this tennis
Factory that's grown into other sports
as well but
at the time it was very ton of specific
and Nic military was someone that came
with a lot of experience and coaching
experience and he as a person was a
mentor to me more than anything with the
guidance with this experience of seeing
so many people come in and out so many
people come in wanting to be champions
turned into turned into good some some
people come in they turn into great and
some just turned into champions and and
he's seen it all so no knocking at the
door of Military Academy and the dead of
the night it was probably one of the
toughest moments and in that journey and
it really began there and they told us
it was a little too too late or a little
too early to be knocking I had an
Academy door so they sent us to a hotel
and we ended up coming back in the
morning and they put me in a group of
kids with probably six or seven kids and
an instructor watched me hit a few balls
and called over Nick Bollettieri and
said you have to see this girl play and
then Nick saw me play and that's kind of
where it took off and what what makes
that place so special and I asked
because I always wonder I mean in the
beginning there must have been something
special in the sauce because there there
comes a point where the best in the
world gravitate to your center if you've
produced a lot of champions so then
there's a question of is it created or
is it sort of a selection bias but what
makes that place unique in terms of
training in terms of principals or or
anything that makes it stand out that's
a great that's a great question because
it's I see it in two different ways and
from a positive view I saw it and I
still see it as first of all it's it's
located in a place where there's nothing
else to do so you are you're going there
to be committed to become a tennis
player or another sport that you might
be practicing over there you have no
distractions the second greatest thing
about it is the amounts of kids that
were there that were older than I was
against whom I was able to compete and
so every afternoon six days a week
I would play matches against them and I
would play sets and it was the best
learning experience because creating
that understanding what you do and who
you are as a tennis player and and those
mechanics the basics the mind the brain
of setting up the next shot before you
even hit it that knowledge you get by
playing and so I had this this
opportunity I'd play a kid from China I
play a kid from Europe that were I was
most like I was what I was not most
likely I was one of the youngest ones at
the academy I at one point I wasn't even
allowed to board there because I'm so
young and so I had this incredible
experience of coming in terms of
competition of seeing someone across the
net that was two feet higher than I was
that was stronger than I was and I had
to figure out how to beat them if I
wanted to you know have my self esteem
or be confident would be a better player
and and the other great thing was that
Nick himself he knew what to say and he
knew when to say it and I think you can
be a great coach and I've had many
throughout my career but they're not
very good business people and Nick Nick
understood that you only need just a
handful maybe a couple or or a few
players that could really make the
academy what it is and you know I
boarded with eight other girls for a
long period of time and and they weren't
excited to be there they knew that that
wasn't their future they sometimes
didn't even know if that was their
College future but the money that was
going into that Academy based because of
why they were there and practicing and
competing was the reason why Nick polit
area was so so smart and when you needed
him he was there I mean 5 a.m. he's
there on the courts he's the one that
locks the place until this day and that
dedication and that love and passion for
what you do I mean that's it's
incredible I just saw him a few months
ago I spent a few weeks there training
part of my comeback
he was out every single day he'd come
out for a few minutes he'd sit down next
to me he you know he'd speak to me like
I was ten years old again and and he's
the same Nick as he was
it's so rare it's really rare to see
that and I go there for the same reasons
I go there because of the atmosphere
because you see other athletes and and
it doesn't matter it's there if they're
in college if they're young if they're
not going to make it just to be in the
environment of everyone training with a
purpose it makes you better it makes you
I love playing in front of you know a
little crowd would kind of get around
the court that I was practicing on and
and since I hadn't been in competition
for a long period of time it was so
great to just to have people huddle
around the court and watch my every move
and and I felt that adrenalin again
because usually in between tournaments I
like to practice where it's a little bit
more private and little quiet and is
that a tournament you know 2zu always
compared to being sort of no escape
until someone just takes you out on a
golf garden and away you go and so when
I'm home whether it's in Florida or
California I just love the stillness and
the quietness of just being on my own I
don't have a court but I go to a country
club and I practice on a corner or or I
train at a private court as well and
just have your peace and quiet a little
bit just to have your mind only see your
team and the members of your team and
then do your work and leave but being
there for that period of time was
brought back so many memories so a few
things number one Nick I'm sorry I
always mispronounce your name any time I
try to say it I always I think part of
my spirit wants to be Italian so I try
to really throw a spin on it and say
what it dat but it's every single every
single day of the weeks that he would
absolutely alright well then you're
welcome Nick not I'm sorry and the next
question is related to your experience
early on you mentioned that you had
these giants across the net meanwhile
you're this tiny
kid holding this gigantic broadsword
basically cuz it's so big compared to
your body I've heard that you had some
experience being teased when you arrived
in the US and I'd love to hear you talk
about that if to any particular examples
come to mind and just talk about what
effect it had on you because with
what-what I have just been mesmerized
might sound weird so don't take it as
being creepy but like just just focused
on when I watch you play and compete is
just the toughness and you mentioned the
grinding and just the the toughness that
I see is something that I'd like to
explore so could you talk about the the
teasing when you got to the US I very
much felt like I was an outcast from the
beginning and one of the the reasons was
because I had arrived in America with my
father and and our story just didn't
make sense to anyone so from the very
beginning everyone just assumed we were
crazy which if I look at that now yes
we're absolutely their decisions
decision was crazy the fact that we come
to America and you have the
seven-year-old girl with a dream to
become a tennis player that's never
gonna work out and and so I I sensed
that I felt that I felt that I was
different I always felt like I was there
on a different mission and because I was
one of the youngest ones I never had the
same interest as the other girls and I
always knew that my interest and my
passion was very different to theirs and
while I boarded at the Academy I
remember coming back you know from
practice and my little locker would be
open and and the only thing I had in
that locker was this giant jar of little
animal crackers and the champions I
don't even know where to look with that
what you died is coming out next but
back then I just remember that giant jar
of animal crackers
but that I believe a friend from the
Academy gave me for my birthday and
that's the only thing I had in that
locker and I didn't have many belongings
I didn't have a lot of outfits or skirts
that the girls had I didn't really have
anyone to do my hair or braid my hair
you know my father would sit me down and
on a chair and just cut my bangs
straight across and they never look
great obviously you didn't doing and so
I was always a little off I I didn't
speak English in the beginning I was
learning through just speaking with all
the other kids because they they talk so
much you just pick it up and you learn
and it just made me feel very much alone
it was not that I didn't have it felt
like I had a lot in common because we
were all there to play tennis but the
mission that I was on and I felt like I
was was very different and it wasn't
that I had to be a champion or I didn't
have to be a champion it was that I was
learning and I was growing to be a
better tennis player and I didn't know
where that would take me but I knew that
in order to get there I had to wake up
at 6 a.m. and I had to practice through
the day and then I would take a
30-minute nap from 12:00 to 12:30 and at
1:00 p.m. I'd be back playing matches
and sets until 4:00 or 5:00 and then I
have a little bit of homework and then I
have to do it again and so there was a
lot of other interest that the girls had
and then posters and glitter and
pictures and David Hasselhoff Janet
Jackson and the time and so I was just a
stranger I was sort of in my own little
bubble from from a very young age and I
look back in those moments and I I've
gotten that question a lot like how did
you feel that you feel lonely and one of
the other things was that I didn't go to
America with my mother because she
didn't have a visa so I went the first
two years in America without seeing my
mom at all and I look back at that time
and I there's nothing about it that
it's sad it was very sad to not have
that that support and not have your your
mother cut cut your bangs and so instead
of your father or him buy you shoes that
are so ugly and you can't you don't you
don't know how to tell him but he
doesn't have enough money to buy you a
better pair so you just keep your mouth
shut it just it didn't feel it didn't
feel like we were doing the wrong thing
I felt like I was on this path that I
was meant to be on and I didn't feel
lonely I didn't feel sad it was a lonely
time because I look at that and of
course I wasn't outcast but when you're
on a mission to do something or be
something and it's not so much about
success I think it's just you know we
always think of like having a vision and
of course we have goals and we planted
in our minds but I never remember one
time when my father told me that I had
to win Wimbledon or that I had to win
the US Open he never made me feel like
if I didn't that the world would end and
I always remember thinking that if this
doesn't work out we would go to Russia
and that's absolutely fine because I
felt like I had a completely normal
childhood when I was living there did
you feel any pressure in the sense not
from your parents directly but in the
recognition of what they were
sacrificing for you to take a stab at
tennis or was that just not a factor at
all whatever they did they never made me
feel like it was and I think that's one
of the reasons why I never felt the
pressure of having to win things or
having to earn money I I knew that I
didn't know how much money I could earn
I I was never really interested in that
I I didn't know anything that would come
with being successful with being a
successful tennis player and you never
really do and I think that's one of the
great things in life is that you you
don't know and that it's it's an
experience and it's for you to
experience and for you to acknowledge
and for you to learn from it and whether
you want to take it or not that's that's
up to you it's in your own hands but the
fact that they gave me this this
opportunity to
create a life for myself is incredible
and now my father's my father remained
kind of the leader and the coach of of
my tennis until I was 21 years old he
traveled with me to every single
tournament and after I won my third
Grand Slam there's very mutually he
decided to stop and and now he's on a
permanent vacation and he thinks he's
training for the Senior Olympics and he
loves to ski and and do all those great
things and I and I'm so happy and it
makes me just incredibly grateful that I
can support that and I that I can do
that for my mom that I could do that for
my dad that they for my extended family
and and they're the reason why I'm able
to do that is it true that you've never
used the word rejection or that you
don't believe in that word is that true
well I don't I mean it's a very it's a
very tough word to believe in that's a
very tough word to accept I think one of
the reasons is is because I saw in many
different scenarios where my father
would say no because he would open up an
opportunity to say yes and could you
okay
please explain mm-hmm so there are many
situations whether it was a coaching
opportunity or whether it was receiving
money from an agency he had this ability
to say no to the things that seem that
like they made sense like the easy way
out because he believed that later he'd
have a better opportunity to say yes
bigger and greater thing right so he
said no to the small shiny objects in
front at the time I'm sure they didn't
seem so not small not cement I don't
know at the time in perception the short
term shiny objects may be right so
rejection it wasn't there was never a
because I always had mean I always was
following and kind of next to my
Father and seeing the decisions that he
would make I was only a kid and even
when I even when I won Wimbledon I was
only 17 years old you're still a kid and
you're still following the guidance and
you know I'd win a match following that
and I'd call it it's where I'd want to
turn him in and I go shopping in a store
and I would call my mom cuz I was
something like quite pricey and I I
didn't know if I could buy it even
though I had earned that money if I
could purchase a piece of jewelry or
shoes or whatever it was at the time
that I wanted so I was always watching
and observing and they never rejection I
mean your of course when someone says no
to you it's easy to say oh yes I was I
was rejected but if you can open up a
different opportunity from that point of
view then you're turning and no into
something that's that brought you to a
better place it sounds like you did that
with your interactions with some of the
other players who were boarding at
Knicks tennis academy in a way do you
consider yourself an introvert and
extrovert a blend how do you think about
that I think from a very young age
because of sort of the process that I
that I went through and the success that
I earned from a young age and winning a
major and a Grand Slam at such a young
age and because it became so unexpected
I went from being someone that was you
know that someone that people Scout it
to being someone that everyone had
analyzed and knew about and wanted to
know more of and I created this you know
I definitely put on these horse blinders
because if I had not my mind would have
been everywhere and I I think it would
have been so easy to be distracted in
those moments and situations and be
pulled in different directions which
it's it's a slippery slope it's very
dangerous
as a young girl it could have been a
disaster to say the least and so I
definitely remember I remember the
moment and it was just a few matches
before I won Wimbledon where I was
sitting down with my coach and all of a
sudden think it was before the
semi-finals of that tournament and all
these tourists who had gotten
credentials they seemed like tourists I
didn't know who they were maybe they
would have have maybe they were maybe
they were important agents or sponsors
but at the time they just seemed like
tourists that I wanted a picture with me
and and it really came overnight and
that sense of WoW everyone all of a
sudden wants something everyone wants
something that you have everyone wants
to be a part of your success I didn't
like that feeling you know I love the
feeling of being in a position of
showcasing what I could do with my
tennis racket but that feeling of
everyone wanting a piece of that and the
feeling of your opponent's all of a
sudden all of a sudden feeling like just
by beating her they're not just winning
a quarter final or the final of the
match but they're winning so much more
it made me it made me feel like I needed
to kind of put myself in a bubble to
concentrate to focus that it was going
to be that much harder that much more
difficult and I did and I don't know if
I could have done it another way what
were some of the what are some of the
best practices or decisions that have
helped you with that because for
instance my friend Josh I was mentioning
earlier who became well-known
effectively overnight particularly with
the movie about his life for chess he
could no longer compete effectively
after that because he would go to a
chess tournament and there would be I'm
making up the age but he's something
like 13 or 14 and all of a sudden
they're 20 girls who want his attention
and a bunch of reporters and he removed
himself completely from the competitive
scene he's one of the most private
people I know at this point
so what what helped you what kind of
decisions or advice or practices I think
it was surrounding myself with good
minds and good people that had my best
interest and it's so easy to say those
words but I know how difficult it is to
find those people and even harder now
nowadays and it was and I started so
many different examples of other other
tennis players and of their success and
their paths after that and the people
that knew all of a sudden associate
yourself with I think as an individual
it's very easy to be affected by the
voices that are next to you because we
listen to that and we we process that
information and all of a sudden we I
won't say we want to be like them but we
reinterpret it in our way but like when
I read when I read a funny book all of a
sudden I feel like I'm a comedian or you
know when I watch this an incredible
acting by someone it inspires me to to
be an actor you know it's like there's
moments of this that that happens as an
athlete you surround yourself with with
people's opinions or choices or money
and wealth and it's very it's such an
easy distraction and and I surrounded
myself with good people and I the
friends that I have today were my
friends when I was a young girl that my
manager has managed me since I was 11
years old you know my mom is still very
much my best friend and another really
good friend of mine I met when I was 11
years old as well so I have I have this
fondness of developing those real
connections with people and I think it
was so helpful for me as a young girl
because I competed in front of thousands
of people and I still do and the walk to
the tunnel and the walk to a press
conference and the walk back in the
hotel room it's a very lonely journey
and that it's a difficult
you're in your mind a lot and you're
thinking a lot so when you have when you
have voices next to you that are the
right voices then it's so helpful but I
know how hard it is to find but I do
believe that that is a big part of my
success I have some public exposure and
have found I've made a lot of mistakes
and I found it really difficult to
identify in some cases what ulterior
motives are or if people start doing me
tons of favors I now realize there might
be something coming six months later I'm
very hesitant to accept favors but I
can't even imagine the level I mean I'm
playing t-ball
and you're in the major leagues in the
World Series when it comes to how many
people want a piece of you and how do
you for instance assess someone if you
say have coffee or lunch with them what
do you look out for or look for I mean
how do you decide whether it's someone
you want to see a second time or talk to
a second time if anything comes to mind
and this is just yes quite frankly I'm
afraid I have 4091
unread email in my inbox clean then I
feel like I've a mess in my head well
we'll talk about that next but in the
meantime I think it's about I love
meeting people and I love having
conversation and I love being inspired
and you can get so much out of a
conversation or about from exposing
yourself to being in an unfamiliar
territory so with people and I'll give
you the a big kind of an example that
was I felt like it was important because
I'm very much I'm always around the same
people so I have it
team which is my coach and my fitness
coach and my trainer and we travel I see
them more than my family we travel
probably 260 days out of the year
together breakfast lunch dinner is
practice training we know so much of
each other and then you have a manager
and then you come home and then you have
your friends so I'm always surrounded by
people that I know and that I trust and
that I love which is incredible but I
always think that as a as a human being
and from a perspective of the mind and
growth and intellectually when you're
put in a situation where you're
unfamiliar with people and you're
unfamiliar with their stories or who
they are and you have to ask questions
and to get that out it makes you a much
more interesting person and so last year
I put myself in this position where I
had all this time off and it was during
the summer and I signed up for these two
business courses in Boston and Harvard
Business School and I was one out of the
40 students I believe in each of these
courses and I stay on campus and these
were individuals who were CEOs and CEOs
of companies of Airlines of Microsoft of
all these incredible brands and I was by
far the youngest and and probably the
silliest and the less the least
knowledgeable one in the room but just
by being with them just by sitting with
them just by sitting with them at dinner
by asking them questions by feeling a
little bit uncomfortable I felt like at
the end of those three weeks
I grew and I grew and and it wasn't that
I mean there are definitely things that
I learned that I I'm applying and that I
wanted to apply in my business but the
biggest thing I got out of it was that I
grew as a person I I became familiar and
in a very unfamiliar territory I still
keep in touch with people in those in
the classes we have completely different
life
they're CEOs of companies they have you
know three or four kids you know they
travel all over the place and Here I am
a 30 year old athlete but there's so
much respect in that room because we're
all trying to learn and to grow and so
when I when you asked me like who are
the people that you want to meet with or
speak to or have a coffee with I always
think of that and the people that I
choose to be with are the people that I
want to learn from and that I want to
have a conversation with and not just
about what they bought at the flea
market or you know what they're gonna
how they're how they like their coffee
but it's about the world and it's about
education it's about people and and it's
not about right or wrong I don't always
have conversation because I want to know
what makes someone perfect and not I
like to hear opinions and I got out of
that experience in Boston and I know I
felt like I grew I felt like I stepped
up and I got out of my comfort zone and
and I followed up with them and we still
keep in touch about business and
projects and things like that so it was
a very interesting experience personally
for me what I like about your answer and
what I think is healthy for me to hear
quite frankly is that I framed the
question by focusing on what to cut out
how do you avoid this how do you find
red flags for that what do you look for
/ / ulterior motive
fill in the blank and somebody said to
me two days ago that is a very male way
of approaching trying to solve problems
to find the cancer and cut it out to
remove it and the way you answered the
question was you didn't explicitly say
this but like here's how I choose who to
spend time with not here's how I decide
who to tease that that you're not going
to be disappointed at the end of it or
they're gonna want something from you
that you weren't expecting right but you
do in order to have you have to put
yourself in a position to find out and
right and what's the worst thing that
what's the worst thing that can happen
from it you don't reply or you don't
answer you don't get back
okay right right it's an acceptable
acceptable cost of tax to pay not the so
the reframing that you just did this is
this is for me right now in my life at
least the really important stuff and I
suspect this is true for a lot of folks
and I'd love to switch gears a little
bit and just ask you about self-talk so
what you are saying to yourself and I'll
choose something very specific when you
are in a competitive situation if you
look back at your your competitive
career up to this point when you've been
down and then come back to win versus
when you've been down and then lost how
does your self-talk if can you think of
any examples are there certain things
that you repeat to yourself consistently
when you come back and win versus maybe
things you forget to say or ways that
you slip up when you end up losing is
there any pattern to that or consistency
there I'd say there's a pattern because
every what's great about the sport that
I play in the situations that I'm in is
that they're all very unique and that's
what that's what makes it so exciting to
do this after so many years and after
being this child prodigy and when I
think of like the motivation that I'm
able to have till this day and until
that that fire is burning I'll always
keep playing but that's the unique part
of it is that you every day is different
every match is different you might be
confident you might be ready you might
be healthy but you never know what's
going to happen and and I'm someone that
loves certainty I love certainty in my
life and I love I do enjoy having a plan
but that's not realistic you know and
and there's so much uncertainty and what
I do so I know that I can prepare my
best I know that I can prepare my body I
can prepare my mind but in any situation
that I'm in it's always different and
you have to react to it differently and
it doesn't always it doesn't always go
according to plan and I don't always
find myself being positive but something
noticed it in my mind actually in the
last match I played and it was in a
match where I got injured at the end of
it and had to actually I was up in the
third set in Rome and I came into the
match being being a little bit upset I
was down and just for other reasons and
I I knew the frame the framework that I
had in my mind was that it was something
along that the words of I can't I can I
can I'm not able to I don't I don't feel
well and not there my mind is not
present and the second that I changed
that and I changed it to I will and I
kept saying to myself I will win the
match and I will win the match it was
like the instance I remember being down
a breakpoint and automatically there was
something in my body language or my mind
just the repetition of what I was saying
to myself it just triggered my body and
became more aggressive I stepped into
the court I took her second serve and I
hit a winner and from that point it just
it changed in the end of the match I was
up believe it was 2-0 or something I
tore a muscle in my hip but then I had
to had to give her the match but I
noticed this is crazy change which I I
don't I don't really notice as much and
it was amazing that it just came this is
a question that you just phrased but it
was the last match that I had played but
it happens a lot I do I'm a very so I
take I do take my time in between my
service games I walk to the baseline I I
move my strings around I I do a little
pep talk and it's very automatic I
wouldn't say there's it's something
crazy or something doesn't have to be
crazy talk what is the I think it's more
it's more of like of putting my eyes
onto my strings and
and having this repetition that it
doesn't matter if I won the point or
lost the point but I'm just on this
level that I'm on this path that I'm on
this like river that is gonna get to
where it's going no matter what rock is
in the way no matter what storm is on
the way the water is ultimately gonna go
down the river and that and maybe prep
talk is not the right way I don't always
I do think that our mind is always
working always saying things and you're
not always so conscious of it but it's
this routine that I have and I think
it's kind of a safe place for me because
in a match it can be an hour match or it
can be in three hour mat match and
antennas momentum changes so much just
like in life one second everything's
positive and you get bad news and you
know someone is leaving the company or
someone's not gonna work anymore or
someone's not healthier and all of a
sudden you go from a great day to Wow
and it's just a way for me I see those
strings and I see my fingers playing
with those strings and and I just I
think of being level-headed and being
not overly excited not down but being in
this like medium frame of mind I would
love to dig into specifically and this
is related serving and you'll start to
notice a theme here that this is also
very self-interested because I've never
learned how to play tennis despite the
fact that I grew up on Long Island
surrounded by people on tennis courts
most of which I was not allowed on I
would serve their coffee but I'm going
to my first tennis camp in the next few
months to try to learn to play yes and
what recommendations would you have
don't do it besides don't do it because
I've already sort of a question scream
jump jumped off the cliff and I'm trying
to grow wings for serving because I
think you've hit up to a hundred and
twenty-one mile an hour serves which
just makes my eyes spin inside my skull
I can't even imagine what that looks
like any tips for
the people out there I'll deep
personalize not Tim but actually for Tim
the people out there who would like to
be better at serving do you have any
recommendations doozer do nots I mean
the one thing that I noticed a lot with
people they're just starting to play
tennis and it's not just about the serve
but it's in all all strokes is that they
take their eye off the ball in order to
see the result or that where the ball is
going which is is a big mistake in the
beginning especially because the more I
contact you have with the ball the more
the strings of your racket are going to
be on the ball itself so seeing seeing
the lines of the ball visualizing that
will really help you kind of maintaining
like when you lift your arm up to hit to
hit a serve sometimes we want to bring
it right back down as we can make
contact so keeping that left arm up is
something that I focus on when when I
make a few errors and as a right hander
yeah as a right hander or if it's a left
hander than keeping your right arm up
yeah I would say those are the two two
top things by the way I am the work I'm
the worst at coaching or I I don't I
don't believe it for a second please do
you're like I've had enough tennis on
one side probably rather commentate I
think you just don't like talking about
yourself I think I don't but you are a
distinct you probably are a very good
coach if you're good player you can be I
think if you get the right questions may
be a good coach so I'm gonna try so
where do you think tennis players
you don't want let's just say novice
intermediate wastes a lot of time like
where do they focus too much or spend
too much time on and where should they
spend more time I think I spent a lot of
time on the outcome
I think that a lot a lot goes into the
result it was that in as it out as long
as it in the net and it all of a sudden
becomes your focus it becomes your focus
point but that's why I mentioned like
watching the ball as long as you can
because it takes your mind away from
thinking if the ball is going to be in
or out
and therefore it I always feel that your
attitude and your your body language and
I've always thought that that's a very
big part of of the game itself and how
you how you're able to transfer this
body language from a mistake into a
winner that you hit and just the next
ball or in a few balls and the sometimes
it's all it takes because tennis is a
matter of really millimeters you could
do the same thing and the ball just the
wind takes it and it's long and if
you're playing in a conditions where
it's not windy you do the same exact
thing and you have the same technique
but it goes in and one day you're
cursing at yourself and you're upset and
the next day you think you just want a
Grand Slam so it's a very it's a very
thin line there there's no doubt about
it but I do I think there's a lot of
there's a lot of attitude that needs to
come down when I watch when I watch no
no watch junior tournaments when i watch
body language when I see facial
expressions and looking over on the
sides of the court and a lot of it is
because tennis is so emotional and it's
so in the moment and and every single
point counts and and you want it to
count and of course it shows how
passionate you are about it but the
attitude and is a very important part of
being a tennis player so in addition to
the attitude or layered on top of that
tonight I I have promised this will be
my last question about Technic
in the first month if you were if you
were coaching your son or daughter in
tennis in the front and let's just
assume they said last thing I want to do
is tennis and then it
like 20 they're like you know what
actually I want to do tennis just make
us dealing with a little kid as a whole
thing in and of itself right but we
could also deep personalize it and just
say you're teaching someone you care
about right what would you make sure
they get right in the first four weeks
what would you really focus on so I
think the the basic techniques and even
when you're young like that's that's the
main thing those are your fundamentals
so if you start if you start if you're
you need to go right and you're you're
going to Big Sur but you turn left from
the beginning you're you're done and
that's how I said that's how I've always
seen tennis is the the mechanical
mechanics are important and they need to
be easy like sometimes I see strokes
that are so complicated and they're so
the backswing is huge and the spins are
crazy and I think it definitely can be
much more simple and it's not about
power it's not about hitting a winner a
lot of it is controlled power like I'm I
mean I play a very aggressive and
powerful game but when I play the best
is when it's controlled power when I
don't want it to be power but when my
when my strokes are simple when they're
not complicated when I'm not trying to
grunt as loud as I can even though my
growth very loud when it's really
compact you know keeping your out
keeping your elbow close to your body
instead of having this huge loop and
really zoning in on the ball I always I
always see people take their eyes off
the ball well I hate to say it but I
think your next book might be about so
I'm not gonna I'm not gonna forget to
mention it but I do want to mention it
you have a new book and I have more
questions I won't keep you here five
hours as much as I want to but you have
a new book unstoppable which I am
actually
extremely extremely excited to read and
I don't my listeners know I do not
actually always say that I'm very
excited to dig into it but can you tell
us a little bit about it and then I will
give one of many reasons why I'm excited
to check it out but could you tell us a
why write a book and because books books
are a pain in the ass and I can speak
from experience completed I just took a
deep breath and I said wow I said wow I
have so much respect for like I can't
believe people do this for a living you
know what I about three years to two and
a half years ago I had a meeting with a
with an agent and I sat down and she
came into the meeting talking to me
about a potential memoir and it was so
far it was just an idea that she had it
was not really even a vision or a plan
she just wanted to talk to me about it
she knew a little bit about my story
about moving to America she didn't know
everything and we had this conversation
and I came into the meeting actually
just taking the meeting because I wanted
to be nice and I never thought that I
was ready to write a book and to to
share so much of what I share in this
book about about moving to America about
facing my rivals about my personal life
about all the experiences that I've had
and in the 30 years that I've lived and
I wrote a few paragraphs myself and she
I yeah she was very it was interesting
because I left a meeting feeling like
wow I'm really gonna write a book aren't
I
yeah and it wasn't anything that she
said it was just the conversation and
her asking me about my story and as I
started speaking about it she was her
eyes lit up and she said it was
incredible and I looked at her leg huh
because I
no I always like I think that everyone's
story is special and everyone gets to
where they are in their own certain
unique ways and I know I just don't go
about my life thinking that I know that
it's very different and that it's maybe
one in a million and that my family took
a chance but I don't walk around
thinking wow this is brilliant
and so I walked out of that meeting
thinking wow I'm like I might be a
writer I might write a book and so I
wrote a few paragraphs myself and in
just a few weeks time we got this offer
with no questions asked
no is this gonna be gossip no who's
who's gonna be part of the story I
signed with Sarah Christian at FSG and
she wanted to hear my story and I don't
know it just it inspired me and made me
feel like there was a lot of
inspirational work that I could put on
paper for for people to read there was a
writer that I had in mind whose name is
rich Cohen you're very familiar with
I am very you made such a great choice
that was one of the things I was gonna
bring up just for people who don't know
and I hate to interject but this is
another thing that made me so excited so
rich is written just some incredible
books one new Weintraub's
and also I mean the fish that ate the
will a which a lot of people have heard
of you know one of my actually two or
three friends one of their favorite
books of all time so I'll let you carry
on but rich you made it he made a great
choice when I read Jerry Weintraub's
book is somewhere on holiday during my
off season November probably I'd say
seven years ago I said to myself that if
I ever write a book that rich Cohen
would help me do it and when I made the
decision to write this book I had my
agent
find out who rich Cohen was where he
lived what he did if he had time to do
this I didn't even know if this was a
possibility
so I let him and this was so fascinating
because I I met with three writers and I
met him at this swanky New York hotel
and and he walked in there just looking
like he did not belong and I knew
exactly that this was my guy that's my
guy I knew that he he knew where he was
going he took the train he had a
shoulder bag on and he was just looking
around he was simple and our
conversation was very simple it wasn't
anything over the top and I knew but I
knew from just meeting with him for 30
minutes that he he was a genius in his
literature and that's where his genius
has come out it's on paper and I got
that sense from the beginning and
another reason I chose to work with him
was because I throughout my life I have
I've been influenced by a lot of male
figures so my father my coaches Nick
military Robert Lansdorp my manager and
I wanted I wanted a rich to sit down
with these people I wanted him to spend
time with these people to really get an
understanding of the characters that
were part of my life that made me who I
am today and I knew and I thought of
these people I thought of my father and
I thought of the person that he would
give the time to that he would open up
to that he would share with and that I
think that was one of the biggest
reasons that I mean he and my father
spent 'seeing over a week together just
talking and talking and and it wasn't
even life life talking stories I mean my
father was able to tell stories that I
that I read in the book and I am I was
like wow wow I was so young that I don't
I don't remember it and yeah he was we
spent so many weeks together I love the
way that he worked I loved loved the
questions that he would I just love the
simplicity of him as a human being
I love the filter also it wouldn't have
even occurred to me at least
in this conversation if you hadn't
mentioned it but the fact that it's not
just who you like and who's writing
you're like but who other people will
talk to because a big part of my story
is the other people that influenced my
life and because I started my life at
such a young age I started this you know
this crazy move and this crazy
profession and and these people were so
influential and they're very much a part
of this part of the reason that I'm here
unstoppable subtitle my life so far man
you have a lot you have a lot of decades
left well you know I I wanted it to be
called to be continued and I got shut
down really fast that's basically
telling everyone to get a new book wait
a second that's been my dream ever since
those because I when I would see memoirs
written by or autobiographies written by
young you know say younger individuals I
would think to myself do they really
think that their life is over and that
this is all they have itself so of
course when you say that you have a book
come out a memoir when you're 30 years
old and I was just so like I had this
vision of calling it to be continued oh
but they're like that you have to
explain what's inside the pages and not
what's coming out know what you could do
yeah you know you see you could have
this unstoppable my life so far then you
write your your coaching book that you
promised me you'd write then then the
third book can be unstoppable my life
continues or it continues and so I think
you could get love to ask some some
micro questions just about routine and
perhaps a couple of other rapid-fire
questions that I'd like to ask before I
get to that I know you've had you've had
some shoulder issues in your life I've
had shoulder reconstructive surgery and
improved sort of mobility and recovered
largely yeah yeah I know
fortunately it's on my non-dominant or
what I was going to ask you you
mentioned some of you were team the
fitness coach and so on what have you
found to help most are there any
particular exercises that have made you
more resilient against injury so for
injury prevention what are some of the
components of say your fitness program
that you think have helped most I like
that you use the word prevention because
a lot of a lot of the makeup of an
athlete is about prevention and it's you
know we do so much to try to prevent
injuries and we don't always succeed but
a big part of the little exercises and
the tedious things and the repetition is
is that and I would say the biggest
component of because I went through
shoulder surgery is the consistency of
keeping up with the exercises you know
there's a lot of exercise out there and
they're all great exercises but it's
very rare that you keep doing them
mm-hmm and I I start every morning after
my shoulder surgery before every
practice I have a routine with a rubber
band it's not that that's not a rare
routine for a tennis player we all warm
up we do about a 30 minute warm-up
before we even get to warm-up on the
court before I match so there are a lot
of little scapula exercises that you do
and this is with a thera-band man right
yeah and a lot of it it's not even about
the weight that you have or the
resistance of the thera-band
but it's the repetition that you do so
the feeling that you have in the back of
your scapula or in the tendons of your
shoulder is that it starts burning
that's when you really know that the
little muscles in between the big ones
are firing and the the more consistent
you are with that the bigger chance of
you getting healthy and also preventing
something else to happen because your
body always compensates so if I have an
injury
on place.you your your body the brain is
so smart that it starts using other
parts of the body and all of a sudden
you feel it somewhere else so yeah yeah
so the consistency of following through
and really keeping at it is for me as
always the most challenging thing and I
see people give up on it what about for
the lower body are there any particular
exercises that you wish you'd
incorporated earlier so I grew very fast
and that's something that I speak about
in the book as well because none of no
one in my family is tall I'm the tallest
one and I talk about the struggles that
I had as a teenager during that period
of time and and my father says it was I
grew because I had the soil to grow and
that I needed it from my sport and that
it was everyone's wish including mine
that I would be taller so I could be sir
from a higher angle or that I could be
more powerful but with that comes you
know you're a little bit less explosive
you're not as mobile you're a little
stiffer and I think movement you know in
tennis you have so many movements that
are just back and forth and changing
direction and so I work a lot on the
joints I work a lot on balance balance
of the core and then balance on a little
unstable izing platforms where I really
work my ankles and my knees make sure
those are all aligned and not wobbling
too much when just gaining the
confidence and sometimes they seem like
the most the simple exercises you know
if you take a picture of them or a video
of them and you they're the ones that
you don't want to post because with
someone who think you're not doing
anything yeah yeah you're not you're not
doing an Olympic weight lifting maneuver
doing any RDOs but the little things
that are that that take time and that
looks so simple and that our boring are
the ones that really you know that they
had the you not only do keep your focus
but you keep your strength in the
balance so yeah and I work I work on my
core a lot because I
do believe that that's it is the center
of your body and it controls so much of
it puts the body together it's like the
glue if you could only choose one or two
core exercises to do what would they be
oh wow I love using the TRX band and do
that yellow band oh yeah and putting it
up hanging it and putting my feet in it
and then doing it yes yes and then sort
of doing like bicycles while you're in a
plank when your feet are in the TRX I
like that so you're crossing your
midline with your knees yes yes it's a
yeah I mean that's a little bit on the
advanced size but I know that your
audience can do it yeah and then you can
also folks if you have really tough top
of your feet you can do that I actually
have some rings I'm looking at outside
on my patio set up a sort of pushup
height and you can do something very
very similar and I do a lot on the
physio ball and that's always simple
most gyms have it even just that also
notice us we're small if people Swiss
ball I see a ball yes they're a lot of
terms yeah I like I like doing all
different types of planks were you know
just floor planks and extending your
arms or extending your legs one at a
time out so it's a good omen of surprise
and imbalance or it's not just static
right and for those of you who have
heard my conversations with dr. Peter
Atia he is a huge fan of doing different
plank motions on the physio ball and
just to your point about unimpressive
exercises so I have completely changed
my lower body performance and just
stability in the last six months using
slant boards which make you look like
you're on the most unenjoyable drug
imaginable but it's this tiny tiny
adjustment that I feel like has changed
my entire lower body by focusing on the
feet so here here
now I have shoe I'm also looking at them
right now I have a bottle of geranium
essential oil I know it's not a Smith
segment but bear with me I have a bottle
of geranium because it was recommended
to me by someone named Nicholas McCarthy
who is a one a one-handed concert
pianist who uses geranium when he is
writing and composing because he found
it helped keep him alert without over
stimulating him so he was relaxed and
alert so at at some point I saw a video
view when you're 14 a started the basil
that's right
candles and aromatherapy are you still
into that right now these oils and all
these candles and yeah well for me it's
about like this feeling of being in your
like home environment and comfort that's
something that you don't get when you
travel so much so when I do that's kind
of my way of feeling like every morning
I turned on my incense and my candles
and my coffee and just the smell it's
like the smell of being home what's the
go-to morning incense
it's a Moroccan scent hmm I don't
exactly know what's in it but it smells
like I'm in Morocco even though I've
never been there another one that's on
my list do you not bring those smells
with you when you travel I don't it you
know interestingly enough I when I go on
a trip like I know that that's my work I
like I like leaving those things behind
because it makes me feel that I'm going
there for a reason and I'm not going
there to be comfortable I'm not going to
be there in my environment I'm there to
do my job and I will come back home and
I'll have everything I'll have my
friends and I'll be around my family but
when I leave it's like there's so many
times when I
I've gone on a plane and it's the middle
of the day and Manhattan Beach and the
sun is shining and everyone's playing
volleyball and and I look at that and
I'm like it's hard it's definitely hard
no my friends are out there and I want
to be out there and I want to be
enjoying the sunset but I know what I'm
going out there for I know that come a
time when I have five days off I'll be
able to take my friends on vacation and
treat them to a beautiful time but now
is my time to work and so I like leading
those things behind because it makes me
feel that there is a there is a prize at
the end of it there is something that
I'm that makes my job different mm-hmm I
don't know if that makes sense it makes
perfect it makes perfect a hundred
percent sense to me and it actually
relates to something that made me smile
when I read it I was looking at a
transcript of a conversation that you
had and this requires a little bit of
context but I'll shorten it I hate the
word balance what is balance because
it's 50/50 that means you're only giving
50% to both things so I've always
disliked the phrase work-life balance
because it implies blending to me and I
like to keep them very very separate all
right do you think that's something that
has helped you more than her you are
challenged to you in terms of
relationships outcomes and everything
else I mean do you think there'll be a
point where you trade that or change
your mind about that I definitely think
that it's challenged me it's challenged
the way that I think but I do you know I
read the one thing a few years ago
mm-hmm I carried out Keller and I really
it kind of hit home for me when you
saying that you when you wake up in the
morning you put your focus on this one
thing of what you want to accomplish
during the day which seems like a
no-brainer right it seems like okay
that's that's the way that everyone
should do it but it's so much more
complicated than that and for example
when I leave for a trip and you know one
of my good friends is getting married in
August and I'm going to be either in
Cincinnati or Toronto competing at a
tournament I know
that I'm not there for my friend it's a
big it's a big day it's a big event and
yet I have this career in front of me
that is taking priority and I could say
you know could give many examples of my
personal life as well but those are
choices those are your choices and those
are I think I don't think that there is
a 50/50 balance I don't that hasn't
worked for me I've always felt that I've
had to let something go if I sacrifice
something if I'm just 50/50 I'm never
100% and I want to be a hundred percent
you know when I train when you train
hours on end when you give so much of
your of your body in your mind to this
one profession and whether it's me
playing tennis whether it's something
else I don't want to come into one of
the biggest moments and biggest stages
of my career and feel that I didn't do
everything that I could right and and
some I do think that some people are
okay with that feeling but I am NOT and
that's my choice and it all comes down
to choice I think we all have them but
as long as that we're as long as I'm
able to say and I do believe that it's
for other people as well as long as we
commit to that choice and not regret
that choice or don't give up don't allow
ourselves to regret that choice then
that's when that's when it's the right
formula for us mm-hmm now you have many
many many choices that are put in front
of you you have people the help but I
would love to talk about choices in the
morning so first thing in the morning
has come up a number of times and I'm
rather obsessed with morning routines so
you mentioned the incense Morocco
you mentioned the tea Darjeeling when
you wake up do you
you breakfast right away what is the
first 60 to 90 minutes of your day look
like in water what's the script what is
the what is the algorithm
yeah it's different all the time okay
what about breakfast breakfast
consistent do you have sort of the for
instance for this week like what is your
go-to breakfast so I'm in training right
now and I'm getting ready to play all
these hardcore tournaments and so for
the last weeks I've been healing an
injury now that that's that's all good
I'm back into the routine of just
intense training every day and so you
know I started a particular time in the
morning I like to wake up early I like
to go to bed early so I wake up early I
like to get about eight to nine hours of
sleep sleep has been a big part of I
just feel like the make up of how I feel
of the energy level that I have yeah I
look up at six-thirty I usually have to
be ready by 9:00 for practice so I use
that time and it kind of depends like
right now I have a few I have a couple
of businesses that I'm a part of so a
lot of like the first hour hour and a
half I spend maybe on a conference call
because that's usually you know
afternoon time in Europe so I'll do one
of those I'll answer a few emails that's
coming in from Europe and have a candy
brand so we have to make a lot of
decisions on that on a daily basis sugar
sugar povo sugar Provo
ash is it true I'm not gonna jump beyond
this but is it true that you can you
were considering legally changing your
name last name for the 2013 USF it
proved to be very difficult but I do
that work for the first hour hour and a
half with a cup of coffee that I have to
have in the morning with lactose free
milk
what type of lactose free milk sorry
Amanda straight on lactose free milk oh
I see so it's not almond milk coconut
milk lassi lactose free real milk and
black history preferred coffee um I do
Nespresso
mmm-hmm simple and yeah I think it's all
for me it's all about the phone I have
to have like the right so I do that and
then and then I usually when I'm getting
ready I turn on the podcast mm-hmm and I
listen kind of depends on the mood I'm
in whether it's about health or I want
to hear about someone's life or
someone's experiences I'll turn that on
so by the time I get my stuff ready for
the whole day of practices and kind of
brushing my teeth I listen to other
people share what are some of your
favorite podcasts well a good friend of
mine is Lewis Howes so I listened to his
Iverson two years a bunch and past six
or eight months I would say to then Dan
Harris's I listened to a fashion one
yeah a little bit of everything so Dan
Harris this is Dan Harris of ten percent
happier
yes all right why do you listen to Dan
Harris because I was going to ask you if
you have a meditation exists of anything
it's interesting someone asked me the
other day do you meditate and I said I
don't but I really feel like I do
because I listen to so many people speak
about meditating and I really I feel
like I do that I had to think for a
second I almost said yes and I was like
no no actually I I don't meditate but I
listen to people speak about it and I
have a little bit I've tried I've done
it and I I enjoy it some of it is a
little it feels a little cultish to me
plenty of that floating around oh yeah
you didn't like the like catspaw and
black roses I sent you trying to tell me
people I'd like to hear about people's
experience of life-changing experience
and I think that's what that's what
really interests me is how something can
affect a person whether it's reading a
book whether it's hearing a mantra
whether it's meditating so that's why I
like listening to people speak about
their
practices or how its influenced their
life or what they were going through
that required that hmm yeah I love
learning from people's experiences so I
think that's one of the reasons I listen
to his so I think I think you've been
meditating your entire life because of
your comfort level your comfort level
with repetition right I think that that
is one in the same in a lot of respects
and some people know where I got it from
but I one thing I do I realize that our
thoughts are so spread out and that they
go in so many different directions and
when I when I notice that my mind goes
to places that are so unnecessary when
we when I create my own stories that are
so far from the truth
I bring it I bring it to I bring it back
to the center of my breath so I do think
about just breathing and that's not like
me sitting in a chair and having
thoughts are saying okay now I'm going
to meditate for 10 minutes that's just
me whether it's on a practice court and
things are not going well or I'm making
so many airs and all of a sudden I just
create the story that is so that is so
far from the truth or the reality it
would be an example of that so say I you
know say my coach has me you know say
I've studied some video analysis and he
showed me a particular stroke that he
wants me to work on or a particular
movement and he you know he said this is
that's incorrect and this is he shows me
an example of what he thinks I should do
a little differently and so I go in the
practice court I start doing that and
with repetition I'm not getting the
outcome that I that I wanted and so I
plant the story that I know he's
incorrect he doesn't know what he's
talking about you know or that no
actually this is not I did this doesn't
feel right this doesn't feel natural I'm
not gonna feel nauseous but doesn't feel
natural now it's not going to feel
natural in a competitive state of mind
and I know all those things are
completely not true those are all things
that I'm putting in my brain how do you
catch that what do you say in your own
head when you catch it I'm so aware of
my surroundings and I'm really aware of
of like the choice the kind of the
inside choices that I make I've had sort
of this feeling from a young age where I
know how my mind can affect others or
like my surrounding and myself included
without having to say one word yeah so I
try to bring it back to my breath and or
sometimes changing those words
completely even though those are also
not true but they're much better than
the negative outcome that you're putting
out into the world I interrupted at some
point which I'm prone to doing because I
get all excited I also want to recommend
well I want to recommend hardcore
history with Dan Carlin if you haven't
heard it I would recommend starting with
tomorrow morning wrath of the cons is
what I would recommend starting with it
is my favorite podcast of all time and
he does one episode every 6 to 12 months
ah but you will see why they are
incredible and also I want to I would be
remiss if I didn't say thank you to Lois
a mutual friend who made the
introduction very good man yes I I think
we didn't get around to it because I got
all hoppity and jumped in right now you
do this you have the espresso with very
important foam you have some conference
calls you take care of sugar poha and so
on then my phone's goes my phone goes in
my bag for the next few hours
mm-hmm and I train when do you eat would
you have for breakfast I eat probably 30
minutes before I get to to practice so I
okay so for two for the first two and a
half three hours you're nice is it
special water no water okay god it's
only $27 Southern California water it's
just no yeah and so I drink that I drink
my coffee and then breakfast I usually
make myself a smoothie or or green juice
with spinach and kale and chia seeds and
coconut water and all the other greens
cucumber Kiwi and I always have a piece
of rye bread and that's kind of the
European I love rye bread so I start
with that and I either put some goat
cheese on it piece of protein or avocado
and some berries and that's it sounds
delicious
I love rye bread but I might my tendency
is to eat a whole loaf of rye bread if I
allow myself a little bit I'm not very
good at that moderation thing well the
thing about rye bread is that I I don't
think that it's so good so that I mean I
but it's not like like sourdough I love
but I don't read that much so if I was
eating a piece of sourdough I'd probably
have three pieces but that's digestible
and good it's not a Snickers bar yeah
all right no this is this is a smart
approach all right this is just just
just a few more things in the last few
years or just in recent memory what is
what is a new leaf or behavior or habit
that has greatly improved your life does
anything come to mind one thing that I
had to go through in the past 15 months
was being away from my sport because of
a suspension that I faced and I went
through this time period obviously with
a lot of questions and questions of
whether I would return to sport whether
turned to the sport that I played but
during that same time I also realized
and I had a chance to stop and really
recognized how and what I've really done
in my life in my career to inspire
others and to know I've used the word
inspire a lot because that's how I kind
of see other people inspire you know my
life but I had so many moments and
instances where I would come across
that would start a conversation with me
and tell me none of how I've influenced
their kids or how I've now they've seen
me compete and that I'm you know they
admire my my spirit so much and that
they can't wait to see me back and I
don't I never had that realization
before which sounds crazy and but I
never really understood or I don't I
don't think I really understood maybe
was selfishly how much I impacted other
people did you notice that because PR
madness was stressful and you saw that
as counter counterbalance why do you
think you noticed it I think I noticed
it because people so many more people
came had had the courage to speak to me
mm-hm and which what's usually you know
people would come up to you and ask for
an autograph or ask for a picture and
just be you know what a few seconds of
your time but these were instances where
people would come and have a proper
conversation with you about how they're
so they can't wait to see me back and
they can't wait to see you play and what
what I mean to them and it was just
different
it was a different communication it was
a different way of talent of you know
and and every person helped me feel
better there's no doubt but it was um it
was chefs coming from the kitchen and
they were pilots coming from the cockpit
and it was just an experience I I don't
think I would have ever felt and maybe
because I never wanted to feel that like
huge responsibility that I did have this
impact and I always wanted to keep
impacting and always be the right
example maybe that that's why I never
quite but I do think that's
subconsciously I don't want to get into
that because maybe that would have added
more pressure you know because as I said
before like my parents never made me
feel that if I did or I didn't make it
that it would be alright to go back to
where we started yeah it was just it was
a very
opening moment now you you had your
first sponsor as I understand that when
you were 11 so we we so when you are
getting that amount of attention and
when you have adulation from fans and
chefs and so on it's it would seem to me
a very human temptation and very easy to
get a very big head and for that to
affect your life and performance and so
on how do you how do you counteract that
or how do you avoid that because that's
been the downfall of many many people
who have been in the lot in the
limelight for various things I will say
that I'm I'm a fairly realistic person
and I know I've been through a lot and
so I face I faced a lot of grief I faced
a lot of press I faced a lot of success
I faced a lot of boardroom meetings I've
seen a lot I've seen a lot in my years
and at the end of it is it's all a lot
of it is superficial and a lot of it
almost seems not human like superhuman
but behind everything there's a very
human person you know there's a very
normal there's a very much a simple
human being that night I've been
fortunate to make good money for my
career but those things are never things
that make me the happiest and I know
that and I realize that the values that
you have in your life are are much
smaller than that and they bring so many
more rewards than money could ever could
ever bring you of course it's helpful
and knowing that I you know that it puts
a huge smile on my face that I can that
I can support my grandparents and then I
can buy them a home and that I know
they're going to be comfortable and they
can have their garden and grow their
cucumbers or that my cousins can have a
proper education and that feeling is
incredible but that's and that's a
feeling that of course money brings you
but
think about it I'm not like I said the
relationship that I've had with my
parents you know they're they're also
very strong people and they they will
tell me if something you know if they're
if they see that something's going on
earth my my decisions are not correct
and they're very real and I surround
myself with real people you know I wanna
I'm a very honest person myself I think
that's part of the Russian character I
say like it is like I said I'm very
straight on about what I feel and that
sometimes gotten me into trouble you
know just based on maybe I should keep a
few opinions to myself but I like this
idea of tell me how you feel about
things tell me tell me straight up you
know don't go around don't you know
maybe I this this word maybe is is
brutal
it's like neither here nor there so it's
hard it's definitely hard because from a
young age I could have made so many
different decisions and that could have
got me to different places what is one
of the worst decisions that you avoided
making or one of the best decisions that
your parents helped you make I mean at
that age there was a lot of decisions
that my parents made but I think from a
business point of view I've been been
able to be associated with many great
brands and there is a lot of
opportunities especially when I was
young to make what I like to call quick
money mmm it's like wire wire in the
bank you show up for a shoot and you do
it and you smile and and you leave and
and there you are and that is it's not
that it's it's great that you have this
company and this brand that you know has
tracked you down and has seen you and I
studied you and wants you to be a part
of their brand but I've always felt like
the best decisions I've made are based
on real partnerships like real
understanding of what a company of what
myself wants from each other and why we
want to work together and I really
believe that's one of the reasons I've
I've had the
partnerships for such a long time I mean
one example was with Nike I mean it's
it's so much more than just me wearing a
swoosh on the court like I I go into a
store and I take pride in fact that
looks I was well actually I was walking
around the other day and someone came up
to me and said wow you look like he
could you could be like a Nike billboard
and I was you know I looked I didn't
know if that was but I looked at her and
I was like yeah and they're so you can
reassure prove oh of course you are they
pay you to they pay to wear that and I
said no actually you have no idea how
happy I am to wear this like you kind of
grow a fondness of the people that you
work with of that there's so much that
goes into a campaign a product a and I
love that stuff I person I love knowing
I got I want to the Nike campuses after
my Harvard experience and I followed
around I went into meetings and I kind
of shadowed I was like a little ghost
and all these meetings cuz I wanted to
learn about like product development
that was a Burton oh yeah
nice so I went into these meetings and I
just I I wanted to know why a product is
dropped and why this material is used
and why that material was being
developed and there's just so much
incredible technology I just I love
fashion I love creativity so I got to
learn a lot about that but you take
great pride in the people that you work
with and and the decisions that I that I
made that started with either a
friendship or a partnership where you
understand the company and you know the
people have are the ones that have grown
I mean you're playing the long game in a
lot of ways and I think there are many
people who feel like they know a lot
about you
so my last two questions are about
things that people might not know about
you and hopefully there's a lot of that
in this conversation already the first
one is if you had to give a TED talk
about something you are not known for no
tennis
for instance what would you talk about
what is the the personal obsession that
few people know about or or something
you're good at the few people know about
that you would talk about or anything I
don't know if I'm good at but I and I
don't know if I necessarily do a TED
talk on I have a huge passion for
architecture and yeah I I think I've
always said that if I was in a tennis
player I would love to I would love to
be an architect I find it's it's like my
it's my happy place like when I am able
to drive around Palm Springs or drive
around Tuscany and see like the
differences and beams and windows and I
love studying that and I just I spent a
few years building a home myself and
that process I could feel if I had the
time which I don't have at the moment I
would just do for fun so yeah that would
be something that I'm passionate about
but not many people know what do you
like about it and do you have any
favorite types of architecture or
architects anything looks yeah
absolutely some from Nitra to Frank
Gehry I love like the indoor and outdoor
feel and I love one when architects are
able to bring nature into a home and
make it feel like you're living outside
but you're kind of in this cocoon
environment I don't know if that makes
sense makes perfect but I've yeah I've
just always been fascinated by how
someone can have an idea and draw some
lines and two years later you have
structure and you have placement and you
have a floor plan and you have this maze
and it actually started from a young age
because I growing up in Florida I went I
was I was invited to for a few
sleepovers and I would go to a sleepover
you know to rich/poor at that time is
like a rich person's home that had four
or five bedrooms that I've never seen a
home that had four or five what are all
these rooms for why is there like two
dining rooms like why isn't why
enough and that's when I became
fascinated with floorplans and like
something connects to another thing and
like the usage of space and in the
details like colors and materials yeah
it was just always really human what is
your personal favorite color
I love neutral colors so I love grays
and darks and no Browns Wow I don't want
to say black because that's when I say
someone a little girl asked me the other
day what's your favorite color
because she wanted she wanted to draw
something for me yellow yeah I guess
it's hard to say I do a little girl who
wants to draw you something black like
the Grim Reaper's cape that's your cover
story very last one and we'll see what
we get is what is an unusual habit or an
absurd thing that you love and I'll give
you an example an example of this asked
Cheryl Strayed this question who wrote
Wilde which was made into a movie and
amazing woman and she said every
sandwich I get has to be in uniform
layers so every bite is as similar to
the next as possible so if she gets a
sandwich and like all the avocados are
kind of over on one side or whatever
she'll reopen it and rearrange it so
that every bite is the same now I'm not
saying you have to have something like
that but does anything come to mind an
unusual habit a weird object and absurd
thing anything that you love that is a
little a few random things like I I
always put my left shoe on before my
right and they're not be not just a
tennis shoe but like any shoe it's like
I never when I'm in a store and I'm
trying shoes and they hand me a right
shoe I'm like sorry the box again myself
to give you a strange look then like for
my out of my match court outfits I don't
like to wear usually people like to wear
the same outfit so if they like did well
in it they wear it again mm-hmm
I mean they wash it but then wear it
again or maybe they don't wash I don't
know so I I do the opposite I don't wear
it again I alternate so you never you
know does that I don't want to wear the
same exact one I'll wear the same
looking outfit but I haven't a different
one so okay but never the exact same
outfit again I love it when you win a
huge iron um I you know I feel like I'm
making a liar of myself but when you win
a big tournament do you have a favorite
cheat food or anything that you
celebrate love sweets I love I love
dulce de leche this cake in Russia it's
called the nan devika it's a honey cake
I could eat that every day like baklava
or is it different no it's a little it's
not as crunchy it's a soft cake I see
it's a layered cake but it's a sock cake
yeah yeah I love cherry like when my
grandmother makes cherry jam I could eat
that by the spoons that's like a
childhood memory yeah so I love I love
sweets Oh makes sense for sugar poker
and well it's great for glycogen
replenishment yes those people wondering
[ __ ] de leche also known as the
crack cocaine of Argentina delicious on
vanilla ice cream and if if it's gonna
keep other people up until 4:00 in the
morning because it'll drive them nuts
are tiel's romanian tables right yeah
that doesn't bother anybody Marie this
has been so much fun I really appreciate
you taking the time and thank you so I
really encourage people to learn more
about your story I cannot wait to read
unstoppable
and people can find you at reassure PO
calm facebook facebook the supports /
Sharapova and then Twitter and Instagram
are both at Maria Sharapova do you have
any final ask of the people listening or
a suggestion for the audience anything
that comes to mind no I just say I hope
that they continue listening to your
work because I when I started I was so
impressed by your interviews and the way
you're able to get a lot out of people
in a conversational form and so keep
listening and yeah and I'm so I'm really
excited about you know the opportunity
that I had to share my story with other
people and to share my journey and you
know sometimes we think that our story
is not special and everyone's story is
very special and I've just been so
excited about being able to put it on
paper and for everyone you know to read
to read it so yeah it's a big it's you
know I've always been a very personal
and private individual so it's sort of a
big moment for me because I share a lot
of frame of mind that I had as a young
girl and as an athlete as a person as a
daughter in relationship so there's a
lot I share that I never thought a few
years ago I would be able to it's
exciting it's a little scary it puts you
in a vulnerable place but I'm very
looking forward to to hearing what
people think of it as well
and a congratulations B we talked about
toughness as one of your defining
competitive advantages the fact that you
recorded your own audiobook like you
think walking through or running a
marathon in the desert with no water is
hard like recording an entire audio book
I had to take a couple days off after
that because I was training in the
mornings and then I'd go and I'd record
six to eight hours for three days good
god and I called my team at the end of
the third and I said I first of all I
have no voice and a second of all like
you have
off tomorrow because they're not coming
yeah it is it is one of the most
comprehensively exhausting experiences
you can imagine in which is why I've
never recorded one of my own audio books
I fall I've done bits and pieces and
then I've tapped out so right so I what
I liked at the end of it was that after
I read it and when you read out loud it
was I didn't want to change a single
thing yeah that is incredibly rare
friend incredible which means that the
book has to be really really good I just
that isn't a really clear no no I'm
telling you that's a really really clear
indicator if you didn't change a it
means it's good B it means that our dear
friend mr. hua I'm kidding I don't know
him but rich Cohen alright I know of his
work really got the voice right right
just really resort to do so I'm excited
to check it out everybody can check it
out and unstoppable you can find it
everywhere and thank you so much for the
time Maria I know that your time is
precious and I know you have a lot of
demands on your time so I really
appreciate it of course thank you I
appreciate it
and to everybody listening you can find
these show notes as usual links to
everything we talked about links to the
architects she named links to
unstoppable itself links to everything
in the show notes at Tim dot blog
forward slash podcast and as always
thank you for allowing me to make this
my job I guess and until next time
thanks for listening
hey guys this is Tim again just a few
more things before you take off number
one this is five bullet Friday do you
want to get a short email from me and
would you enjoy getting a short email
for me every Friday is that provides a
little morsel of fun before the weekend
and five bullet Friday is a very short
email where I share the coolest things
I've found or that I've been pondering
over the week that could include
favorite new albums that I've discovered
it could include gizmos and gadgets and
all sorts of weird [ __ ] that I've
somehow dug up in the the world of the
esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's 4-hour workweek com all
spelled out and just drop in your email
and you'll get the very next one and if
you sign up I hope you enjoy it this
episode is brought to you by a scent
protein the cleanest least processed
protein I've ever consumed and I have
tried just about everything since well
before the 4-hour body I've started my
day with 20 to 30 grams of protein first
thing that has been part of my routine
but I don't always have the time or
necessarily the desire to cook an entire
meal so what to do protein powders can
be a fast way to get this protein need
met but most products are full of crap
they're bleached they have excess sugar
terrible artificial sweeteners or just
straightforward low-grade low-quality
protein a scent contains zero artificial
ingredients and the parent company is
actually a cheese manufacturer so that
they produce their own native proteins
it's it's really fascinating and I've
looked at their processing it takes or
it took them about five years to develop
you can mix the protein as little as
four ounces without any clumps or issues
of mix ability whatsoever and they
nailed the taste they tested it for
instance there's the chocolate version
282 different four
they put a lot of money and a lot of
time into RMD for this particular
product and they have both way and
micellar casein so if you want to say
improve body composition and recovery
overnight slow release you can take the
micellar casein or in my case whey
protein I would take post-workout for
instance or in the morning so check it
out these guys are really fascinating
visit ascent protein dot-com forward
slash Tim that's ASC ENT PR OT ein
dot-com ascent like first ascent going
up ascent protein com forward slash Tim
and you will receive 20% off your entire
purchase if you want a very quick xx 30
gram dose to start your day or after
workout this is a fantastic option it is
arguably the best that I found so again
check it out
ascent protein comm forward slash Tim
this episode is brought to you by kettle
and fire which makes some of the best
bone broth and certainly the most
convenient that I've ever found and I
have a big stack of them on my kitchen
counter right now I have one container
every morning and this first came highly
recommended to me by past podcast guests
such as Amelia Boone who's a four-time
world champion in bed stops mutter
Spartan race etc and dr. Dominic
D'Agostino The Incredible Hulk of
scientific research check him out too
but there are a few things that make
kettle and fire special number one they
are the first shelf stable in other
words never frozen
bone broth that uses bones from 100%
grass-fed organically raised animals so
you are what you eat ate if that makes
sense so it's very important that you
understand if you're consuming animal
protein what they consume they also use
longer cook times 20 plus hours which
means more collagen and other nutrients
for instance they contain 19 times more
collagen than one of their close
competitors and an independent lab
confirm this
I'll leave the competitor's name out of
it because I don't want to get sued but
that's the case and it is not frozen so
thanks to many millions of dollars of
packaging equipment their bone broth
doesn't require freezing or shipping
with dry ice so like I said it's just
sitting on my kitchen counter in
boxes and then I can keep them up
they're basically ready to drink
keep them up on stovetop or in a
microwave and you are ready to rock and
wall you also get a nice payload of
glucosamine glycine along with the
gelatin and everything else that I
mentioned so check it out I have been
hugely pleased with this and like I said
have been consuming it every morning it
gives you about let's say 20 grams of
protein which is a nice little slow carb
diet' boost if that's what you're
looking for and I'll typically sip this
out of a very large camping coffee mug
as I do some writing or journaling so
there you have it check it out it's
delicious I favor the chicken but each
to his own or her own so check it out
Hetal and fire compote slash team and
you can receive 20% off of your entire
order take a look
kettle and feiyr.com forward slash tip
[Music]
you